I feel like Dexter meets Aina Garden
it's not every day that I come across a
food that really surprises me but there
I was editing a video where people took
us grocery shopping around the world and
somebody from me from Finland submitted
this
the least favorite ones that sweet Vlog
it says it's flood of a pig
pancakes made from blood
that's different these pancakes are
common all around Northern Lapland so I
called my friend Bjorn and asked if he
could help film a story Bjorn I've got a
story for you hi I'm Bjorn I'm a
documentary filmmaker that travels the
world making stories that here in Sweden
we actually have a dish called bloody
pudding and I remember that this was
even something that we were served in
the school canteen when I was a kid so I
traveled to Yuka Sierra v a small town
outside kirana to film this so we're
gonna do two things we are first
learn from the source all
I'm gonna make them and try them
so let's leave my living room
[Music]
the Sami people are an indigenous
community living in the region of sampi
which includes Northern parts of Norway
Sweden Finland and Russia like Ida Maria
and her family about 10 of Sami people
work as semi-nomadic reindeer herders
which means they travel to follow their
reindeer as they migrate this is
foreign
[Music]
after learning this of course I am
curious so I had to find blood reindeer
blood obviously not so common in New
York City but I went to a butcher shop
in Brooklyn New York called winner
Butcher and I got two pints of pig's
blood
so we're gonna strain this because oh
God
okay it looks like a murder scene in
here ultimately this is a simple recipe
it's just the blood flour eggs salt and
a bit of butter everything just gets
mixed up together and cooked on a stove
it looks like raspberry jam
since I'm in New York City I'm cooking
it on my pan on my stove as I do not
have access to a campfire we'll just
have to make do
they kind of look like chocolate I don't
I mean I know it's not chocolate but
it's just the feeling like Ida Maria
suggested I've got bacon and lingonberry
Jam I'm just gonna put a little bit of
syrup on top
I don't have much experience with blood
dishes I've had many types of blood
sausages like Sunday from Korea black
pudding from the UK that actually might
be it but cooking with just liquid blood
like this that was a first just a little
bit of uh lingonberry Jam the idea of
the pig's blood with the bacon I really
feel like I'm you know getting the whole
animal in here Ida Maria ate it with her
hands and so I will as well
[Music]
I'm not gonna lie if you didn't tell me
there was blood in this I would have
thought that the texture is off
there's definitely an earthiness to this
but I think the biggest difference for
me is a texture I know this might be
weird but it kind of reminds me of a
stingray body there's kind of a
rubberiness to this can you see that
having some with some bacon
bacon is salty and it makes everything
taste great ultimately like am I going
to be serving blood pancakes from now on
on Sunday mornings you know probably not
although I do have some leftover blood
I know that a lot of cultures do cook
with blood I'm curious for those of you
watching leave a comment and let me know
is blood a part of the culinary
landscape in your country and what is a
blood dish that you would recommend now
that I'm kind of in it you know I'm in
the blood Zone if you've made it to the
end get some blood try a blood pancake
you won't be disappointed awesome